well Malik first of all I want to tell
you you are my pick to win the
tournament so hearty congratulations for
another Victory congratulations like
people in your dreams yes yes so far
you're doing well Malik now I want to
start with uh this position because your
aggressive stands early on in the
opening really surprised us I mean you
can play E6 and go for the usual typical
ways to try to equalize the position but
then you just invite tomorrow yeah which
is six yeah you are ready for a fight in
this one always yeah absolutely and did
you do that because Dmitry was maybe
struggling in the event a little bit
well firstly yeah I saw that with a
struggle in a tournament so he missed a
win against novikov clearly winning
position yesterday he messed up against
and he even forgot that actually quite
known end game uh sort of theoretical
End Game King F2 and then and he showed
it immediately after right right I saw
the broadcast but I knew the position as
well so I knew this I think and then
game supposed to be drawn so I figure he
struggled then another thing is um he I
don't recall him playing like uh English
opening he usually plays D4 C4 right so
when he played against me C4 I'm like
okay my main move is E5 but he perhaps
prepared against it or something like
that so I figured what what do I do to
make a fight so I played C5 I was still
expecting him to do something with G3
but then when we played marocy I'm like
okay well he played that motor you're
right I mean I could have played like E6
and should be a five right but I mean
one idea I had in my rocks which
actually not no it's Bishop E5 which
happens in the game yes so you knew all
of them oh yeah absolutely yeah because
Bishop E5 a happened to me as white
against the Grand Master Ahmad
michaelian and I lost the game as well
that's white
but I played better so you understood
that practically it's not easy to do
yeah but when I lost the game I came
home I analyzed very deeply I prepared
this line for China Olympiad as well so
I thought maybe it will need it so I had
some files on it I didn't repeat it
today but I remembered all ideas so yeah
it's a very rare move and you have to
know like how to react it so it's not
easy I believe I played against Armand
myself I played through D1 and no I
played Rook fd1 actually
so you also started with Rook ab1 yeah
yeah yeah or kb1 is actually fine it's
okay but then E6 a computer was showing
to bring that B5 this is the kind of
idea what computers uh uh I believe uh
it's not mistaken I forgot uh details
but but not here maybe not here maybe
maybe earlier than that before then or
something I remember it was a div of
Knight B5 at some point maybe
G3 you see G3 and then I'd be fine
that's right play G3 it's a rook let's
say G3 Queen E7 and 95 7. something like
that yeah but you already have player
not true D1 you play G3 and meet E6 with
not B5 yes
G3 A6 not B5 so you're supposed to
challenge this this expand ASAP yeah
right if you don't do that then uh you
might be in trouble because you get this
F5 idea absolutely yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I figure like he doesn't
know this position he has no experience
but clearly he didn't know what to do
yes and I missed something right I
definitely missed something I'm not sure
you did no I think 25 here no I think
Rook G3 was winning yes a little
slightly better but Bishop G3 maintains
the advancement I sort of wish you the
three wins exchange I thought okay this
is a guarantee for me to win and um you
know what I would say is you better have
a you know some material
they would say like yeah they're
building your hands then uh you know
hooking in the skies right so I I wasn't
sure if I'm going to and also I was a
little bit nervous to be honest so
this is one of those games when you do
your homework and whenever you do your
homework uh it's payoff you know that's
very satisfying yeah all right like I
said I I knew the positions I know those
like all the ideas and unfortunately uh
Dimitri didn't knowledge the situation
Bishop P5 which is it's a very tricky
treatment for this for this line you
said uh last year that you came with
high aspirations and unfortunately it
didn't pan out but right now it's
starting to feel like this might be your
tournament are you feeling like that as
well or still too early to call it
taking day by day you know game by Day
game by game so I'm just enjoying uh I
said to begin before I came here I said
you know what it's important to find
some kind of balance in your life and
which luckily
lately I found and I kind of feel
less pressure I'm just enjoying play the
game and uh that's it excellent guys any
questions for our leader right now in
the senior section no I mean
congratulations what a great home
preparation I was saying that I think I
remember we were preparing it uh I don't
know if in Trump's Olympiad or somewhere
because I remember looking at this line
the bishop E5 and queen H4
um together with you but I don't know if
you remember that
she was saying that you guys prepared
this in Trump so perhaps yeah yes idea
with Bishop E5 and you were looking at
it with her right yeah it was like 2014
right you're right but back then um I
think with I think what was it the same
exact position with Bishop B5 and then
E6 Financial idea yes I do remember this
uh Bishop B5 is a queen H4 uh but 2016
or 2018 Baku no Toronto was 20 2014 we
we oh yeah yeah but again I mean I
played this in 2022 in summer uh no 2021
I think
um I play against
together then I came home I just uh
analyzed through my engines and uh I
knew like all those ideas I knew why
it's supposed to be better but you have
to like like I said you have to like
really understand this position to to
treat properly otherwise it could be
really tricky right and I love to play
against model to somehow from very
beginning of my life I always love to
play against my and I couldn't handle
like asthma player my first win as
maruti was when I beat Jack open in the
first round yeah yeah
incredible because to me it was too slow
for me it was always like easy to play
as black because I knew the way how to
handle it yeah but for what I thought
that's too much you know too much of a
build up yeah exactly slowly slowly yeah
congratulations and uh we'll see you in
the rest of your games yeah thank you I
appreciate it and um yeah
so far so good so far so good indeed and
lots of uh